some of this people pick on Bezos
about
I don't even get it
like they're like you see he has like a
new hot girlfriend I'm like yeah what
they're like how lame is that I'm like
is that lame
they're like yeah he's Bluff now too I'm
like is that bad
they're like yeah what a dork I'm like
what does dork mean now they're like
yeah he took his hot girlfriend and his
buff body to Coachella I'm like he
sounds like he's killing it dude
like I don't even know what part of this
we're making fun of
like we picked on him for going to space
in a cowboy hat
what
would be cool to go to space in a cowboy
hat
I know everyone's just flipped and now
all this shit's uncool
thank you